[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه في الرياض نستعرض معكم ابرز
المستجدات نبدا بالعناوين
روسيا تتقدم في ضخمه وتتلقى مفاجاه قرب
عاصمتها وتحذرك من اي استفزازات باسلحه
كيميائيه
ارتفاع وحصيله قتل الزلزال الى اكثر من 51
الفا واتهامات جديده بسرقه المساعدات في
سوريا
اليابان توجه رساله لواشنطن تحديث قدراته
العسكريه لن تكون احاديه او معتمده على
الولايات المتحده
تحقيقات الفيدرالي الامريكي تحسم الجدل
بشان كورونا وتعيد نظريه سابقه حادث محتمل
في مختبر يوهن
دخلت حرب اوكرانيا في مرحله اكثر صعوبه في
ظل اندلاع جبهه قتال ساخنه شرق البلاد في
محيط بخموت الوضع صعب جدا هذا ما اقر به
الجيش الاوكراني والرئيس ايضا
اكثر من مره اليومين الماضيين بان المعارك
تزداد تصعيدا وصعوبه ومع الضغط العسكري
الروسي في بخموت واحتدام الجبهه الشرقيه
تفاجات موسكو بمسيارات تصل بالقرب منها
حادثه غير مسبوقه منذ بدء الحرب هجوم
بمسيارات اقتربت احداها من العاصمه
الروسيه ثلاث اسقطت في شوارع بيلوجرود
وجسم طائر سقط في منطقه اديكا لكن الحادثه
الاكثر لفتا للانظار تمثلت في الاعلان عن
اسقاط مسيره في بلده كولومنا على اطراف
العاصمه موسكو
[موسيقى]
وفي تفاصيل معركه بخموت المشتعله كثف
الجيش الروسي الهجمات المحاصره للمدينه
حتى تمكن من قطع ثلاث طرق اوكرانيه لعبور
الامدادات اما الجانب الاوكراني الذي وصف
الاوضاع بالمتوتره للغايه اطلق طائرات
مسيره استهدفت البنى التحتيه المدنيه بحسب
ما اعلنه الجيش الروسي وبعد اتهامات موسكو
امس بالتحضير لاستفزازات بمواد كيميائيه
حضرت الخارجيه الروسيه كياف من اجراءات
وصفاتها بالمتهوره قد تهدد حياه الالاف من
الناس وذلك بشان معلومات حول استفزازات قد
تلجا اليها القوات الاوكرانيه لاستخدام
مواد مشعه كما حثه الخارجيه الروسيه
المنظمات الدوليه الى الانتباه الى
البيانات المتعلقه بهذا الامر ياتي ذلك
بعدما اشارت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه الى رصد
مدرعات امريكيه الصنع تحمل مواد كيميائيه
الى خطوط التماسي في دومباس
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر
وايضا من موسكو مراسله العربيه كاتيا تعمي
اهلا بكما ابدا معك رائد يعني ما هي اخر
التطورات فيما يخص تطويق
بخموت في ظل تصريحات مثل ما ذكرنا
اوكرانيه غير متفائله وتقر بصعوبه المعركه
نعم ما اراه يا صباح الخير بالفعل يعتبر
محور باخمت هو الاهم في المعارك
المتبادله القصف المتبادل ايضا هنا في
مقاطعه على جميع الجبهات الجنوبيه
والشماليه واطراف المقاطعه بالفعل يوم امس
شهد وفاه مواطن وتسعه اصابات هنا في
المدينه بعد قصف اوكراني باقل من 200
قذيفه وصاروخ ايضا القصف الروسي لا يستثني
المدن المجاوره والمتاخمه وخاصه المدن
التي فيها قواعد عسكريه كبيره واهمها ضخمه
تقدمت قوات فاجنر في المحور الشمالي نحو
بلده بلدانوفكا نحو الغرب المقصود من
الشمالي الغربي وبالفعل هناك قتال شوارع
اطراف بلده باخ متكا تقدمت ايضا قوات
فاغنر من الناحيه الش الى
بلده خروموفكا بعد ان سيطرت على احياء حي
ستوبينكي ايضا هناك المحور الشرقي حيث
تتقدم ايضا في العمق قوات فاجنر نحو نهر
باخ موتكا والحديث عن شارع شيدره
ومصانع اللحوم والمسالك وعده مصانع في تلك
المنطقه يعني تتقدم فيها رغم وجود جيوب ما
زالت للقوات الاوكرانيه في تلك المناطق
المحور الجنوبي ايضا تقدمت فيه القوات
الروسيه الخاصه قوات فاجنر وسيطرت على بعض
الاحياء منها حيث باشكا بالفعل هناك تقدم
على شكل نصف دائره في العمق عمق المدينه
رغم ان المنطقه الغربيه هي الوحيده التي
ما زالت مفتوحه امام الجيش الاوكراني
وتقول الدفاع الروسيه بان نيران المدفعيه
تقصف جميع طرق الامدادات التي توصل الدعم
العسكري بالذخيره والجنود للقوات
الاوكرانيه المتمركزه داخل المدينه حتى
الان ما دامت القوات الاوكرانيه تدافع
فهذا يعني ان بعض الامدادات تصل راويه
ربما لم تنتهي شمال الغربي والجنوب الغربي
نعم نعم
اتم السيطره على هذا المحور اي بلده
بردانه وتقدموا حول مدينه قسنطينه في
العمق من الناحيه الجنوبيه الغربيه فهذا
يعني ان طوق او الحلقه تكاد تكتمل وهذا
يزيد الضغط على القوات الاوكرانيه
المحاصره داخل مدينه باقمت والتي تواجه
وضعا صعبا حسب تصريحات السلطات الاوكرانيه
انتقل الى كاتيا كاتيا اسقاط مسيره
اوكرانيه بالقرب من العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
يعتبر سابقه ما الاضرار الماديه والسياسيه
الذي خلفه هذا الاسقاط
مرحبا راويه حقيقه المسيرات الاوكرانيه
ليست هي المره الاولى التي تصل او تصيب
الى الاراضي الروسيه كنا قد شهدنا مرارا
وصول لكن المره الاولى من موسكو
التي تصل
هي المره الاولى التي تصل الى ضواحي موسكو
طبعا خمسه مناطق تعرضت الى هجوم من قبل
مسيرات منها ضاحيه موسكو طبعا كانت قد
تريد استهداف
مواقع تابعه لشركه غاسبروم وهي عباره عن
محطات غاز سقطت بقرب منها لم تصل او لم
تصل الى الهدف هي من نوع كما تحدث خبراء
عسكريون
141 ستريج وهي مسيرات تعود الى فتره حقبه
الاتحاد السوفيتي هي قادره على الاف
الكيلومترات طبعا كان هناك توجيه اتهامات
ان هذه المسيرات طبعا هي جاءت الجانب
الاوكراني استهدفت المواقع كما ذكرت لك
الموقع الاهم وهو ضواحي موسكو لاول مره
ولكن ايضا كما تحدث خبراء عسكريون ان
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو طبعا هي محصنه
بانظمه الدفاع الجوي التي هي قادره طبعا
على اسقاط اي مسيره قد تستهدف العاصمه
والان تتابع السلطات ايضا بعمليه تكثيف او
تحصين العاصمه الروسيه موسكو من امكانيه
دخول او اختراق مجالها الجوي من قبل
المسيرات طبعا بالاضافه الى ذلك هي خمس
مناطق منها ايضا كانت استهدفت ايضا وبرج
متوازي مع هذا كان هناك اغلاق مؤقت للمجال
الجويه وما امس فوق مدينه بدرسبورغ والذي
طبعا بررته روسيا بانها قامت باجراء
تدريبات
تدريبات عسكريه بالاضافه الى قوات الطوارئ
شاركت بها عمليه امكانيه استهداف طبعا او
اختراق المسيرات الجويه فوق مدينه بدرس
ايضا كان هناك اتهامات روسيه منذ يومين
بمواد كيميائيه تابعه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تم رصد ذلك قيل من الجانب
الروسي هل عرضت فيديوهات هل هنالك من
معلومات مفصله حول هذه المعلومه لان هناك
تشكيك حولها
صحيح يعني على اليوم الثاني على التوالي
تتحدث موسكو عن وجود وصول مواد سامه
كيميائيه يوم امس حدثت الدفاع الروسيه عن
وصول نحو سته عشر صندوق الى مناطق متاخمه
ولكن اليوم
عادته تحدثت على لسان متحدثه الرسميه باسم
الخارجيه خاربه قالت ان هناك قلق من
امكانيه استخدام النظام في كيف للمواد
الكيميائيه بالقرب من مدينه بريدنيستروليا
وهي طبعا كانت ايضا كانت توجهت اتهامات
بامكانيه حدوث استفزازات او هجوم من قبل
الجانب الاوكراني على هذه المنطقه مرارا
حتى الان حقيقه لا يوجد صور تم نشرها من
قبل الاجانب الروسي طبعا عن هذه الصناديق
التي وصلت وكانت تدعي موسكو طبعا كما تقول
ان هذه الصناديق مصدرها هي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تحتوي على مواد سامه
قد تستخدمها القوات الاوكرانيه وتتهم فيها
موسكو بان موسكو هي طبعا لهذا العمل
استفزازي وليس الجانب الاوكراني كما تقول
الخارجيه الروسيه طبعا رائد ماذا يقال حول
هذه النقطه استخدام مواد كيميائيه
باوكرانيا
باختصار لو سمحت
دائما ما يعني راويه دائما ما توجه الدفاع
الروسيه والسلطات المحليه هنا اصابع
الاتهام الى الاجانب الاوكراني ويعني
والجهات الامريكيه التي تفتتح مختبرات
كيميائيه في المناطق التي تدخل القوات
الروسيه وتسيطر عليها وتعلن دائما عن
اكتشافها لمخابر لصناعه ادويه ومختبرات
كيميائيه لتصنيع ايضا اسلحه كيميائيه
وتقول روسيا بان لديها ادله على يعني
كشفتها في هذه المختبرات وستقدمها في
الوقت المناسب لكن باستمرار هناك في
مريوبل كان اكتشاف لمختبر كبير ايضا في
المناطق المجاوره من اواخر معاقل الجيش
الاوكراني في مقاطعه لوجانسك في ديسي
وسيرفز دانياسك تم اكتشاف ايضا مختبرات
كيميائيه حسب السلطات المحليه هناك شكرا
لكما رائد الاخبار وكاتيا تعمي مراسله
للعربيه
وعلى وقع التصعيد في ضخمه وتاكد القائم
باعمال دنيا
في المدينه لاول مره مضيفا ان هذه
الدبابات لا تختلف عن غيرها من الاهداف
الروسيه جاجين اشار ايضا الى ان دبابات في
بخموت لا وجودها لا يستحق اثاره ضجه كبيره
على حد قوله مبررا ذلك بان الطرق متوحله
في الوقت الحالي ما يتسبب باعاقه حركه
دباباتي
رئيس مركز الاوراس للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
اهلا بك سيد رمضان يعني اكثر من تصريح
للرئيس زيلينسكي تحدث عن صعوبه المعركه في
بخموت وايضا هو اقل منذ يومين قائد القوات
المشتركه ماذا يعني ذلك
من هذه المعركه هكذا اخذ السؤال
هل تسمع انا اسمعك سيد رمضان سؤالي لك
تحدث عن صعوبه المعركه في بخموت وايضا هو
اقاله قائد القوات المشتركه الا يعني ذلك
الفشل في معركه بخموت واماكن اخرى
نستطيع ان نقول هناك فشل ربما يعني قال لي
المسؤول العسكري هذا التاتي في سياق اعاده
ترتيب العمل واداء القوات المسلحه بتجربه
اخرى
وفعاليه جديده اما صعوبه الوضع طبعا صعبه
وهو اكد ذلك لان الوضع بدا يتازم وبدا
الحصار وتطويق المدينه من طرف القوات
الروسيه والان المعركه انطلقت الى وسط
المدن المدينه
واصبحت يعني الامور
يعني عصيبه اولا ربما سيكون يعني قطع
الامدادات لان الطرق التي تؤدي الى من
العمق الاوكراني بتقديم الامداد اللغه
الذخيره فاصبحت تطاردها يعني القصف الروسي
وكذلك المدفعيه الروسيه اذا الوضع عصيب
حقيقه يعني نستطيع ان نقول ان ربما نحن في
سيناريو مدينه ماريوبل الذي كان يعني في
السنه الماضيه يعني الان ربما نستطيع ان
نقول ان القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه اصبحت
محاصره وفي كماشه من طرف القوات الروسيه
ولا نستطيع ان نقول ان هناك سقوط يعني
سيحصل ولكن هناك توقع لتسقط المدينه
توقعات وليس اصرار او جزم لهذه السيناريو
موسكو تحدثت عن اسقاط مسيره لاول مره قرب
العاصمه موسكو وهو يعتبر تصعيد خطير هكذا
وصفته سيد رمضان فعليا هالكياف مستعده
لهذا التصعيد خاصه يعني اذا دخلت الصين
على خط تزويد موسكو بالمسيرات وهو ما تم
تسريبه من درش بيجل الالمانيه بانه هناك
اتصالات وحديث عن استعداد الصين لتزويد
موسكو ب 100 مسيره مشابهه لشاهد
حقيقه الصين
تفنن ذلك ولكن التسريبات الغربيه تفيد بان
الصين ستذهب الى دعم القوات الروسيه بهذه
المسيرات اذا دخلت الصين في هذه اللعبه او
في هذا المسرح تبع حضره الصعيدي على
المستوى الدولي والورقه الصينيه التي طرحت
من اجل الوصول الى السلم الى المسار
التفاوض يعني بسبب هذا الاداء وهذا
التصعيد وهذه ستكون مرحله جديده في
الاداء الدولي وكذلك الازمه الاوكرانيه
وستدخل منعطفا يعني مغلقا فان
مساله التفاوصه يعني
لن تكون والده للاسف الشديد والبعض يعول
على الورقه الصينيه فاذا تحقق هذه
المعلومات وتورث التصميم في مساعدتها
للقوات المسلحه الروسيه يعني نحن سنذهب
الى اين نفق مسجد من ناحيه التقاعد
ساتوقف مع زاويه مهمه تتعلق بالمساعدات
العسكريه الغربيه لاوكرانيا بما انه
تحدثنا عن موضوع التسليح واعود اليك اشارت
صحيفه
المناقشات داخل الكونجرس اثناء جلسات
استماع لمسؤولين كبار في البنتاجون وذلك
بشان مراقبه المساعدات العسكريه التي
ارسلتها الولايات المتحده الى اوكرانيا
وقالت الصحيفه ان اعضاء من الحزبين
الجمهوري والديمقراطي طلبوا من مساعد وزير
الدفاع لشؤون الامن الدولي تقريرا بشان
مزاعم ضياع الاسلحه وتحويل مسارها المخصص
للاغراض الحربيه واكد المفتش العام في
البانتاجون روبرت ستورتش ان المساءله عن
الاسلحه الموجهه لاوكرانيا امر هام ويتطلب
مستوى غير مسبوق من الاشراف واضافت
نيويورك تايمز ان الشكوك المتزايده حول
هذا الامر تهدد اجماع الحزبين على مساعده
اوكرانيا عسكريا ما قد يشكل ع امام الرئيس
الامريكي في الحصول على موافقه من
الكونجرس لتمويل المساعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا من جديد اعود اليك سيد رمضان
يعني المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه مهدده
يعني يكون عليها رقابه بسبب الفساد في
اوكرانيا اصلا الرئيس رئيس الوزراء
الاوكراني بمقابله امس مع العربيه تحدث عن
هذا الفساد وكان هناك تقرير ميداني لفتني
لشبكه سي بي سي الامريكيه قالت فيه بان
30% فقط من الاسلحه الغربيه التي ترسل الى
كياف فقط 30% تصل الى وجهتها وهو رقم كبير
جدا
انتم ذكرتم
لكن رغم ذلك فان السياسه الامريكيه يعني
هي مستمره في دعم
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه بالسلاح وكذلك
دحم ميزانيه الدوله فهذه السياسيه السياسه
خارجيه وسياسه الدوله العميقه الامريكيه
هذا الذي يؤثر من هي الحزب الذي سياتي الى
الحكم حتى بعد الرئاسيات القادمه في
الولايات المتحده ولكنه سيؤثر على حجم
المساعدات
ترزح تحت حرب دخلت عامها الثاني
انا اؤكد لكم بان الحرب في اوكرانيا هي
حرب اطلسيه وجوديه
مرتبطه بحسابات عميقه ضد روسيا وسياسات
روسيا في المنطقه فان الغرب والولايات
المتحده وجد تحديد سيذهبون في دعم الدوله
الاوكرانيه مهما كانت الارقام ومهما كانت
المسائل الاخرى المرتبطه بالفساد
والمرتبطه بماء يحصل فيه سواء في الداخل
الامريكي او في الداخل الاوكراني هذه
مسائل هامشيه لان في العمق والاساس وفي
فلسفه الغرب او المنظومه الاطلسيه هو
انهاك واستنزاف روسيا بكل مهما كان الثمن
فالمساله الفساد هي وارده ولكن ستعالج
بطريقه اخرى رغم ذلك فان الدعم يتواصل وان
الامريكان سيجدون طريقه من اجل فرض
المراقبه او ارسال هذه المساله او هذه
الذخيره
عبر قنوات قنوات تكون مشدده اكثر شكرا لك
رمضان
رجحت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه نفاذ مخزون
روسيا من الطائرات المسيره التي تستخدمها
في عمليتها العسكريه الجاريه حاليا في
اوكرانيا واشارت الوزاره في تقريرها الى
انخفاض وتيره الهجمات الروسيه بمسيارات في
اوكرانيا خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين واشارت
الى انه من المحتمل ان تسعى روسيا للحصول
على امدادات جديده من الطائرات المسيره
واستندت الدفاع البريطانيه الى عدم وجود
تقارير عن استخدام الطائرات مسيره فيها
هجمات منذ الخامس عشر من فبراير شباط
الماضي وحتى قبل يومين وفي مقابله خاصه مع
العربيه اتحدث رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني
دينيس عن ملفي محاربه الفساد في بلاده حيث
كشف انه خلال الاشهر او الشهر المقبل سيتم
تعيين رئيس لمكتب مكافحه الفساد لمتابعه
هذه القضايا
اربعه اجهزه حكوميه في اوكرانيا الشرطه
والمخابرات ومكتب مكافحه الفساد ومحكمه
مكافحه الفساد وخلال شهر مارس سيتم تعيين
رئيس مكتب مكافحه الفساد في اوكرانيا تكمل
الاجهزه المعنيه التحقيقات في ملفات عده
وانا مقتنع بانه حتى النصف الاول من شهر
مارس ستكون الحكومه وعينت رئيس المكتب
الوطني لمكافحه الفساد
نشرتنا مستمره فيها بعض الفاصل
1000 دولار في متاجر المواد الغذائيه
الكبرى
اهلا بكم من جديد في زياره هي الاولى لها
منذ 6 سنوات زار امين عام الامم المتحده
انطونيو غوتيريوس بغداد حيث يجري محادثات
مع المسؤولين العراقيين غوتيريش قال بعد
وصوله ان زيارته تاتي للتضامن مع
العراقيين والمؤسسات الديمقراطيه
والالتزام في توحيد مؤسسات البلاد كما
اعرب عن ثقته بان العراقيين سيتمكنون من
تجاوز الصعوبات والتحديات التي يواجهونها
بفضل حوار مفتوح وشامل
لقد اتيحت للفرصه لاكون مع العراقيين
النازحين داخل البلاد ورايت صمودهم
وشجاعتهم كما اوتيحت للفرصه لزياره
اللاجئين العراقيين في الاردن وسوريا
ورايت كيف تمكنوا من العيش في تضامن مع
بعضهم البعض ومساعده بعضهم البعض اود ان
اشيد بالجهود التي تبذلها الحكومه للسماح
للعراقيين خارج البلاد بالعوده وسندعم هذه
الجهود بشكل كامل تود مره اخرى ان اعبر عن
تضامن العميق مع الشعب العراقي واملي ان
يواجه العراق مستقبلا من السلام والازدهار
بمؤسسات ديمقراطيه راسخه
وانضم الينا من بغداد مراسل العربيه سامر
الكبيسي اهلا بك معنا سامر يعني من التقى
غوتيرش حتى الان من الساسه العراقيين
وماذا في جدول اعماله
في البدايه صباح الخير راويه الى الان لم
تعلن وزاره الخارجيه عن بيانها فيما يخص
لكن بحسب المصادر هناك لقاء ثنائي بين
غوتيرش ووزير الخارجيه العراقي فؤاد حسين
في مقر وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه سيتم بحث
مجموعه من الملفات على المستوى الدبلوماسي
على المستوى الانساني وحتى على مستوى دعم
الصحه والتعليم من قبل الامم المتحده
للحكومه العراقيه بحسب المصادر ايضا
غوتيرش من المقرر ان يزور محافظه
نينوى تحديدا احد المخيمات الموجوده هناك
وهي مخيمات النازحين اضافه الى زياره الى
اقليم كردستان للقاء القاده السياسيين
هناك وبحث ايضا ملف النازحين المتواجدين
في اقليم كردستان وسبل عودتهم الى مناطق
سكناهم ان كان على مستوى المناطق المحرره
او حتى بعض اللاجئين المتواجدين بسبب بعض
الاعمال الارهابيه المتواجدين خارج مناطق
سكناهم سامر وكانه يعني مجمل هدف هذه
الزياره هو لدعم موضوع اللاجئين
راوي على ما يبدو من تصريحات في المؤتمر
الصحفي الذي عقد فجر اليوم مع وزير
الخارجيه العراقي فؤاد حسين هو لبحث ملف
غلق هذه المخيمات وعوده النازحين الى
مناطق سكناهم على مدى ثلاث حكومات لم تنجح
هذه الحكومات في اغلاق هذه المخيمات على
الرغم من العمل المستمر من قبل الحكومات
هذه الحكومات المتواليه من حكومه السيد
حيدر العبادي وكذلك عادل عبد المهدي
والسيد مصطفى الكاظمي وصولا الى محمد شياع
السوداني تم اغلاق عدد ليس بالقليل من
المخيمات لكن ما زالت قضيه اللاجئين تشغل
الامم المتحده من جانب والحكومه العراقيه
من جانب ايضا رويال على على يعني على ذكر
الملف النازحين واللاجئين هناك مخيم الهول
والذي تعمل عليه الحكومه العراقيه تعمل
على اعاده العوائل العراقيه الموجوده هناك
في سوريا الى العراق واعاده دمجها في
المجتمع نجحت الحكومه العراق في اعاده عدد
من العوائل لكن اعداد ليست بالقليله تقدر
ب 30 الف نسمه من العوائل العراقيه كانوا
من ضمن العوائل التي خرجت وهي ما يطلق
عليه عوائل تنظيم داعش موجوده في مخيم
الهول على ما يبدو ان وجود جوتيره هنا في
بغداد سيسرع من زخم او سيزيد من زخم هذه
العوده الى العراق وبالتالي ربما هناك
ستكون برامج لاعاده النازحين ودعمهم من
قبل الامم المتحده شكرا جزيلا لك من بغداد
مراسل عربي يا سامر اللباسي
دعا السفير الفلسطيني في الامم المتحده
رياض منصور مجلس الامن الدولي الى اتخاذ
اجراءات لحمايه المدنيين الفلسطينيين بعد
الهجوم الذي شنه مستوطنون اسرائيليون على
قريه حواره في الضفه الغربيه قال منصور ان
بلاده ستستمر في ترق باب المجلس ليس فقط
من اجل التحدث بصوت واحد ولكن من اجل ان
يتخذ اجراءات اخرى وان الحمايه هي ما
يطلبه السكان الفلسطينيون
نشرتنا مستمره فيها بعض الفاصل
بين فرنسا وايطاليا ازمه عالقه على ضفه
المتوسط المهاجرون الغرب
في بخمه وتتلقى مفاجاه قرب عاصمتها وتحذر
من اي استفزازات باسلحه كيميائيه
ارتفاع وحصيله قتل الزلزال الى اكثر من 51
الفا واتهامات جديده بسرقه المساعدات في
سوريا
اليابان توجه رساله لواشنطن تحديث قدرات
طوكيو العسكريه لن تكون احاديه او معتمده
على الولايات المتحده
تحقيقات الفيدرالي الامريكيه يحسم الجدل
بشان كورونا ويعيد نظريه سابقه حادث محتمل
في مختبر ووهان
اهلا بكم من جديد بدات السلطات اللبنانيه
اليوم تسعير السلع الغذائيه في محل سوبر
ماركت بالدولار وبينما حددت وزاره
الاقتصاد تاريخ اليوم لتعميم العمليه اعلن
عدد من المتاجر عدم جاهزيته بعد للاجراء
وبان اليه تغيير الاسعار تحتاج مزيدا من
الوقت وتزامنت عمليه دوله الاسعار برفع
سعر الدولار الجمركي من 15 الف الى 45 الف
بطلب من وزير الماليه وموافقه الحكومه
وبينما كان لبنان قد بدا الدوله بطريقه
غير رسميه باتت الدوله مكوننه في ظل
انهيار تاريخي للعمله اللبنانيه التي الذي
لامست فيها سعر صرفها 90,000 مقابل
الدولار حول هذا الموضوع تنضم الينا من
بيروت مراسله العربيه
غنوه يتيم اهلا بك غنوه يعني منذ بدايه
ازمه الدولار بلبنان كان المواطن عندما
يريد ان يشتري شيئا ان يذهب الى السوبر
ماركت ويتم احتساب او تغيير الاسعار حسب
سعر صرف
السوق السوداء هذا معروف ما الذي تغير
يعني من دوله هذه السلع
لانه بحسب يعني وزاره الاقتصاد طريقه
التسعير من قبل لم تكن واضحه ولم تكن
واحده لدى جميع التجار اليوم بدات الدوله
رفيقه سوبر ماركت هذه واحده من السوبر من
المتاجر التي بدات بتسعير بالدولار عندما
يدخل المواطن يرى سعر الصرف اليومي على
مدخل السوبر ماركت وهذا هو يعني هذا
مطالبت به وزاره الاقتصاد اضافه الى وضع
سعر الصرف على على الصندوق بطريقه بطريقه
ممكننه عندما ندخل الى السوبر ماركت نرى
نرى ان هناك نوعين من التسعير هناك بعض
البضائع التي لا زالت
بتسعيرها باللبناني كالخضار كالخضار مثلا
ولكن ايضا هناك بضائع اخرى لا تزال بسعرها
باللبناني وهي التي ااا يعني التي رفض
التاجر تسعيراتها بالدولار نرى هنا مثلا
هذه
على هذا المنتج سعره لا يزال باللبناني
لان التاجر الذي يوزع هذه البضاعه البضائع
رفض ان يعطي السوبر ماركت التسعيره
بالدولار ولذلك بقيت التسعيره باللبناني
وايضا المنتجات بعض المنتجات اللبنانيه
بقيت تسعرتها بالعمله اللبنانيه هذا
المنتج هنا مثلا تسيرته هو بالدولار يعني
يعني وهذا رقم صغير يعني صغير الحجم لم
نعتاده منذ فتره طويله منذ بدء الازمه لم
نعد نرى هذه الارقام الصغيره الحجم ولكن
في حال احتسبت على سار الصرف بالطبع
للمواطن الذي يقبض اللبنانيه هو سعر مرتفع
بعض الشيء هل سيفرض على المواطن ان يدفع
بالدولار هذه البضائع المسعره بالدولار
المفروض انه يدفع بالدولار او يمكن ان
يدفع
باللبناني حسب سعر صرف الدولار
من يفضل الدفع بالدولار يمكنه الدفع
بالدولار ولكن لا يمكن اجبار احد على
الدفع بالدولار يدفع على سعر الصرف الذي
شاهده على مدخل السوبر ماركت او على او
على الصندوق لاحظنا ان هناك عدد من
المواطنين الذين كانوا
شاهدوا سعر الصرف الموضوع وكانوا عندما
ياتوا لي شراء المنتج يبدا باحتسابه على
الليره اللبنانيه خاصه وان هناك عدد كبير
من المواطنين في لبنان الذي لا يزال يعني
راتبه راتبه راتبه باللبناني ولكن يعني
عدد كبير ايضا يرى بانه يعني هذه
يعني هذه الطريقه لم لم لا يوجد فرق بينما
كيف كانت الاسعار في وقت سابق وكيف هي
الاسعار الان لانه بالفعل كان هناك دوله
مقنعه للاسعار يعني ربما لم يكن هناك
تسعير بالدولار وهذا الذي سالتك عنه
بالفعل يعني لذلك المواطنون اليوم يعني لا
يرون ان هناك فرق كبير بالتسعير وايضا
هناك اشكاليه موضوع سعر الصرف يعني نحن
نعلم بان سعر الصرف يختلف في اليوم الواحد
وايضا ربما يختلف من صراف الى اخر فما هو
السعر الصرف الذي سيعتمده التجار والمحلات
التجاريه وهل سيكون هناك رقابه من قبل
وزاره الاقتصاد على موضوع تسعير سعر الصرف
يعني ايضا هنا اشكاليه ربما قد لا تحل
موضوع موضوع اختلاف الاسعار شكرا جزيلا لك
هذا المنتج مثلا باللبنانيه نعم نعم يعني
نشاهد هذه الجوله التي قمت بها في احدى
المتاجر الكبرى حيث شاهدنا عمليه تسعير
السلع الغذائيه بالدولار في اول يوم على
دخول هذا القرار تنفيذه شكرا جزيلا لك
الى تركيا حيث اعلنت هيئه الكوارث التركيه
عن ارتفاع حصيله القتلى جراء الزلزال في
تركيا وسوريا الى اكثر من 51 الف قتيل كما
تسبب الزلزال والهزات القويه اللاحقه في
اصابه اكثر من 108 الف شخص في تركيا
وايواء الملايين في خيام هيئه الكوارث
التركيه اوضحت ايضا ان اكثر من 160 الف
مبنى تركي انهارا جراء الزلزال في كارثه
تعدل اسوا في تاريخ البلاد قرابه شهر مضى
مشاهدينا منذ وقوع الزلزال في تركيا
وسوريا الا ان المساعدات وحتى هذا اليوم
لم تغطي حتى نصف الاحتياج جراء حجم
الكارثه حيث كشف مارتن جرافيث امين عام
الامم المتحده ان الاستجابه الدوليه ضعيفه
للنداء الذي اطلقته المنظمه لجمع نحو 400
مليون دولار مساعدات لضحايا الزلزال تلك
الاستجابه كانت بمعدل 42 بالمئه للضحايا
في سوريا بينما ضحايا تركيا
التمويل الاغاثي الا 7.4% ما يلبي
الاحتياجات الطارئه فقط للاشهر الثلاثه
المقبله كشف ايضا عن احتياج خمسه ملايين
سوري الى ماوى الذي يعيش معظمه في الخيام
الان لكن باعداد تكدس مرتفعه مقارنه
بمساحه تلك الخيام معاناه ضحايا الزلزال
وصلت الى مرحله خطيره وفق الامم المتحده
التي كشفت عن تضاعف معاناتهم بالتزاول مع
ارتفاع اسعار السلع الغذائيه وانتشار
الكوليرا من قبل وقوع الزلزال فضلا عن
العنف والاستغلال الذي يواجهونه هؤلاء
الضحايا خاصه من النساء والاطفال
[موسيقى]
وبالاضافه الى شح المساعدات افاد المرصد
السوري لحقوق الانسان ان ثلاثه فصائل
مسلحه سوريه في منطقه غصن الزيتون يسرقون
المواد الاغاثيه والانسانيه التي دخلت الى
المنطقه عبر المعابر الحدوديه واوضحت
مصادر المرصد السوري ان المتضررين لم
يتلقوا حتى هذه اللحظه اي مساعدات انسانيه
امميه او حتى عربيه وانضم الينا من مدينه
كوفنتري البريطانيه مدير المرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن اهلا بك
سيد رامي يعني من هي تلك الجهات ولمن تتبع
وعلى اي اساس استندتم في قولكم بانها تسرق
المساعدات العربيه والامميه نعم نعم صباح
الخير الجهاز هي العمشات او ما يعرف بفصيل
سليمان شاو والحمزات او فرقه الحمزه
والسلطان مراد هذه الفصائل تعمل في منطقه
عفرين وهذه الفصائل هي مشدود لها بالسرقه
وليس بحسن الاخلاق حقيقه الامر سابقا
كانوا يصرخونها الصين وبعد ذلك سرقوا
المرتزقه على من استفدنا على هذه منطقه
الجلديه الذين هم تضرروا من الزلزال
شاهدنا بمشاهداتهم كان هناك سرقه لهذه
المساعدات او الاستيلاء عليها بعد ذلك
تجري عمليه اعاده توزيع المساعدات وفق
شراء الولاءات من قبل فريق او السلطان
سليمان شاه او فرقه ابو ابو عمشه وايضا
فرقه الحمزه والسلطان مراد لتوزيع هذه
المساعدات وفقه الشراء الولاءات وايضا بعض
القيم التي جاء بها على اساس انها هي تبرع
من الدول العربيه وبعض السوريين يجري
بيعها الان باسعار مختلفه من المنطقه الى
اخرى اي ان السرقه موصوفه وليس يعني لدينا
شهادات ليس 10 شهادات او 20 شهاده بل مئات
الشهادات من ابناء عفرين من ابناء جنديرس
الكرد ابناء تلك المناطق الذين ايضا ليس
فقط فرقه المساعدات بل سرقت منازلهم
المقدمه تحت زريعه او محاوله رفع الانقاذ
تجري سرقه هذه المنازل من قبل هذه الفصائل
القائمه على رؤوس هؤلاء السوريين في تلك
المنطقه ومثل ما قلت لك لدينا شهادات
كثيره من ابناء عفرين ولدينا شهادات
بالصوت وشهادات مصوره هناك خشيه حقيقه
الامر عندما يتحدث البعض الى الاعلام يجري
اعتقاله من قبل هذه الفصائل المشرفه على
تلك المناطق برعايه المخابرات التركيه طيب
حسب الشهادات السيد رامي التي اطلعت عليها
شخصيا وتقول بانه هؤلاء يخافون من الحديث
اعلانيه عن الموضوع خوفا من تلك الفصائل
المسلحه كيف يتم سرقه تلك المساعدات يعني
هي تدخل عبر المعابر الحدوديه بقوه السلاح
وباي طريقه
بجيش وطني الى اخره على اساس انها لديها
منظمات عامله في تلك المنطقه بمجرد ان
تسلم لبعض المن يجري الاستيلاء عليها من
قبل الفصيل تذهب الى مستودعات هذه الفصائل
بعد ذلك تخرج هذه المستودعة المدفعلات من
مستودعات الفصائل وتوزع على اساس انها
مكرمه من هذه الفصائل وليست مساعدات عربيه
وهميه جاءت الى تلك المنطقه ايضا يعني
القضيه يعني يسرقون اراضي الناس ثم تضع
فيها القيام على اساس انها اراضي تابعه
لهذا الفصيل من الفصائل يعني كان هناك
اشخاص مسنين يبكون ويتحدثون معي ويبكون
قلت لهم يعني لا نستطيع العمل الا توجيه
رسائل للجهات الدوليه او النشر الموضوع
بالاعلام اكثر من ذلك لا استطيع فعل شيء
نحن بالنهايه لدينا قدره محدده نستطيع
العمل بها ولكن ان يخرج علينا مثلا فصيل
مثل الفصيل ابو عمشه فجاه
يشاهده بانه بدا يوزع مساعدات لم تكن
موجوده لدي واذا بها هي مساعدات عربيه
وايضا دعيني اقول لك في قريه حمام على
سبيل المثال
نشرت 30 خيبه في تلك المنطقه بعد ان
نشرتها المنظمه الانسانيه مجانا للابداء
تلك المناطق
جاءوا بهم ليلا
درامي شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المعلومات
اعتذر عن المقاطعه اذا مدير المرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان
وهنتابع مشاهدينا هذه الصور المباشره من
اليونان لحادث اصطدام القطاريين حيث
ارتفعت حصيله ضحايا الحادث في اليونان الى
32 قتيلا يعني هناك طبعا
هذه الحادثه ليست الاولى من نوعها ولكن
خلفت قتل
بعدد 32 قتلا كما ذكرنا
الى اليابان حيث اكد رئيس وزراء اليابان
فوميو كيشيدا انا خطط تحديث القدرات
العسكريه لن تكون احاديه الجانب ومعتمد
على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه فقط وقال
في خطاب بالبرلمان الياباني ان حكومته
تسعى لامتلاك القدره على تنفيذ هجمات
مضاده في اراضي اي عدو محتمل واشار ايضا
الى ان اليابان لن تشاركا في سباق تسلح مع
الدول الاخرى رصدت وزاره الدفاع
التايوانيه تسعه عشر طائره التابعه للقوات
الجويه الصينيه في منطقه الدفاع الجوي
الخاصه بها ووفق بيان الوزاره فانها
سجلتها في الساعات 24 الماضيه وكلها من
طراز جي 10 وصلت الى الركن الجنوبي الغربي
من منطقه الدفاع الجوي التايوانيه
تصدر بولا تينوبو مرشح الحزب الحاكم في
نيجيريا سباق الانتخابات الرئاسيه بفوزه
على اثنين من اقرب منافسين بحسب النتائج
الرسميه النهائيه التي اعلنتها مفوضيه
الانتخابات في اكبر بلدان افريقيا من حيث
التعداد السكاني بالاضافه الى تصدره
النتائج على المستوى الوطني فقد حصد تينو
ايضا على اكثر من 25% من الاصوات في ثلثي
ولايات البلاد على الاقل في 24 من اصل 36
ولايه بالاضافه طبعا الى منطقه العاصمه
ابو جا وهو شرط لابد منه لفوزه بالرئاسه
تتقاذفهم الامواج والبلدان وما بين فرنسا
وايطاليا حاولت ازمه المهاجرين غير
الشرعيين جنوب البحر المتوسط الى مقبره
جماعيه تكدست فيه جثث 26 الف مهاجر منذ
عام 2013 الى اليوم وفق بيانات المنظمه
العالميه للهجره وفي كل مره يزداد العبء
على الذين دفعوا بانفسهم الى التهلكه ظنا
بانهم سيصلون الى بر امن لكن الابواب توصد
في وجههم وتبتلعهم الامواج احد هذه
الاجراءات قيام فرنسا بفرض اجراءات امنيه
غير مسبوقه عند حدودها مع ايطاليا لضمان
عدم نجاح اي مهاجر قادم من روما في العبور
نحو اراضيها تشمل هذه الاجراءات محطات
القطار والطرق السريعه وقرى حدوديه ساحليه
وجبليه اما عن اخر حوادث الغرق فكان لمركب
على متنه 100 شخص من بينهم 64 لق وا حتفهم
قباله سواحل ايطاليا ومنذ نوفمبر الماضي
تصاعدت الازمه بين فرنسا وايطاليا بشان
المهاجرين فيما يحاول الاتحاد الاوروبي
احتوائها لرئب التصدعات بينهما بعد
اختلافهما حول تقاسم اعباء المهاجرين
واللاجئين المتدفقين بكثافه
[موسيقى]
ثلاث سنوات عجاف مرت منذ ازمه وباء كورونا
الذي اشتاحها العالم وخلال هذه الاعوام لم
تتوقف الدراسات حول منشا هذا الفيروس
العالم لا يزال يبحث في الامر مدير
تحقيقات الفيدرالي الامريكي كريستوفر ري
حسم الجدل الى حد ما وقال انه وفق تقييمات
تحقيقات المكتب منذ فتره طويله فان اصول
الوباء هي على الارجح حادثه معمليه محتمله
في مختبر موهان مشيرا الى ان العمل بشان
تحديد مكان نشوء الوباء لا يزال مستمرا
لكن العديد من التفاصيل المتعلقه بالتحقيق
لا تزال سريه معتقدا ان الصين تعمل على
تقويد التحقيق من جانب الولايات المتحده
واعضاء اخرين في المجتمع الدولي
تشهد المتاحف الفرنسيه الكبرى التعافيا في
اعداد زوارها بعد ثلاث سنوات من انتشار
جائحه كوفيد 19 وقد سجلت الارقام ارتفاعا
ملحوظا عام 2022 يقترب من تلك التي شهدها
عام 2009
علينا الوقوف لوقت طويل في صفوف الانتظار
حتى نستطيع الدخول الى متحف اللوفر
فالاقبال عاد كما كان قبل الجائحه فبحسب
الارقام الاخيره بلغ عدد الزوار سبعه
ملايين وثمائه الف في عام 2022 اي بزياده
170% عن العام الذي سبقه
لا يبدو انني الازمه الاقتصاديه تاثيرا
مباشرا على نسبه الاقبال في المتاحف
الفرنسيه الكبيره فرغم الصعوبات المعيشيه
التي يعاني منها كثيرون الا ان نسبه
الاقبال عادت وارتفعت بشكل ملحوظ في عام
2022 كما هو الحال في متحف اللوف
منذ ان اغلقوا كل شيء زادت رغبتنا بالسفر
والقيام بالانشطه
جئت الى هنا لرؤيه الموناليزا والمتحف من
الداخل وهنا ايضا في هذا المتحف الذي
تحاكم مجسماته الواقع
عددا حيث استعاد متحف الشمع الشهير بريقه
مع ارتفاع عدد زواره في الفتره الاخيره
وهو المتحف الذي يحتفل هذا العام بفكره
سنويه المئه والاربعين لافتتاحه
بعد سنوات الصعبه التي مرت على متحف الشمع
اعداد زوار الان تقريبا تضاعفت مقارنه
بقبل الازمه الصحيه فالسياح عادوا باعداد
كبيره مثلا خلال عطله الاسبوع استقبلنا
4000 زائر وهذا امر جيد ومفاجاه جميله بعد
كوفيد
وتميز العام الماضي بحضور كبير في المتاحف
للسياح الاوروبيين والامريكيين على حساب
السياح الصينيين الذين كانوا ممنوعين من
السفر بسبب قيود كورونا زينه عادي العربيه
باريس
نهايه النشره تذكير بابرز العناوين
روسيا تتقدم في باخموت وتتلقى مفاجاه قرب
عاصمتها وتحضر كياب من اي استفزازات
باسلحه كيميائيه
ارتفاع وحصيله قتل الزلزال الى اكثر من 51
الفا واتهامات جديده بسرقه المساعدات في
سوريا
اليابان تواجه رساله لواشنطن تحديث قدراته
العسكريه لن تكون احاديه او معتمده على
الولايات المتحده
التحقيقات الفيدراليه الامريكيه تحسم
الجدل بشان كورونا وتعيد نظريه سابقه حادث
محتمل في مختبر ووه
ان للمزيد من الاخبار والتحليلات العربيه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]